so you may or may not have been
following the trial of Donald Trump's
campaign chairman Paul Manafort he's of
course been indicted multiple times his
trial is now going on and the judge
who's overseeing the case is T Ellis and
he has reportedly been receiving so many
threats including death threats from I
believe it would be supporters of
Manafort and Trump although some are
claiming that these are left wingers who
are angry that Ellis is giving too much
to the defense but we'll talk about that
a little bit later the death threats
have been so significant that TS Ellis
is now under US Marshal security
protection he also has decided he's not
going to release the names of the jurors
for fear that they'd be put in danger
which I think makes perfect sense he
shouldn't do that
quote from TS Ellis he said I have no
reason to believe that if those names
are unsealed there won't be threats
against them the craziest thing about
all of this is that this is only Paul
manna for its first trial this is one
about money he made while he was
peddling pro-russian influence in
Ukraine it relates to lies that he told
banks into financial institutions this
is just the first trial against man
afford and of course the people issuing
the threats against TS Ellis that is a
crime threatening a federal judge is a
crime the people issuing the threats
faced significant jail time if they're
caught if they're prosecuted if they're
found guilty but this is very very
serious stuff and the most bizarre part
about the entire story to me like the
zaniest little detail is that the judge
said he was surprised that people felt
so strongly about this case that they
would send him death threats he's on
record as saying quote I had no idea
this case would excite these emotions I
can tell you that frankly the first
major case in one of the most important
cases stemming from one of the most
important investigations in the history
of the United States relating to this
very long list of possible crimes in
which the president of the country was
involved how could a judge be shocked
that that's riling people up like it
seems completely obvious that it's going
to rile people up well I don't know
because I think Trump supporters can
kind of dismiss
man afford as some coffee boy he was the
campaign manager but it was only for a
few months and yeah
Kellyanne Conway soon enough replaced
him so it's not that big of a case
you're also though dealing with what are
effectively mobsters here right that
also leads to the threatening of people
who are either a judge or jury when it
comes to the case I found myself
wandering over the weekend are indeed
the threats coming from wacky trumpets
or Paul man affords Russia connections
and the answer is probably both but then
at the same time you have those who are
saying David know these are leftists
it's the leftists who are the violent
ones and they are angry that the judge
seems to be giving to the defense so
many things that they want the truth is
we don't really know that there have
been a bunch of sidebars during the case
the contents of which have not been
published yet even though judge Ellis
has said at the conclusion of the case
he would consider publishing the content
of those sidebars
if indeed judge Ellis is being careful
to not be I guess I would say overly
harsh against the defense it may be
because he's trying to avoid a mistrial
right because if indeed it can be shown
that he was unfairly partial against the
defense whatever the results are of any
individual sidebar decision there may be
calls for a mistrial and I think that
most judges don't want to lose a case to
a mistrial we really have no idea okay
what we do know is that Trump and his
associates have the mindset of win
however you can win if they can win
fairly I guess that's fine if they can't
then whether it's intimidation or
threats or coercion we know that that's
also fine fine for them I also sort of
find this interesting because we know
Trump has these unhinged rabid fans who
support him no matter what he does and
beyond any benefit to them to even to
their detriment in some cases but it's
hard to imagine them really caring that
much about Paul manna for like who cares
what happens to Paul Manafort yeah I
feel like this is the dozens and dozens
of threats it may just be a few and we
should take those threats seriously
right and the US Marshal should be
involved in protecting this judge but is
it a widespread problem or is it just
coming from a few people we don't
necessarily know how many
threats there are but enough for the US
Marshals who do not mess around to say
we are going to put the judge under
under protection